hello resignation is Greg Alva here with
the lovely Iwama Lauren Lauren Francesca
I want my Lorne is a thing I say to my
instagram every day this is a reason why
i go follow her there and she makes some
awesome youtube videos and she's on all
other social just think of a social
media platform yes she has an account ok
good wife's names to it hey Lauren yeah
this trailer got sent over to me by a
lot of people called feed Oh pan and
feed me feed me
hey that's it that could be something I
don't know what disturbing somatic
material okay
drinking all involving teens I'm like
ready gentlemen moment of your time
please
to celebrate my wonderful sister with
Draco Malfoy tom felton he ever speak
everything you've ever touched if it
didn't wear something really what this
is your life okay just comes down it'll
do for me the world's about them doesn't
even seem possible lose it witness it
will be on difficult sugar twins I've
ever loved no you're bad
whoa what the hell's going on they have
a little battery you can seem
particularly stressed or anxious this
faster
are you want to thank you so I knew that
they listen is to be able to talk to him
not really hearing his identity
we were die together I didn't with such
wonderful
[Music]
I would never hurt you control always on
it but not how it works you have to do
this much become
[Music]
vacation
[Music]
I'm pretty sure there's an incest thing
happen right yeah I feel like that's
part of the imagery that we saw this
there's like some sexual thing happening
here yeah between them I don't know I'm
wrong about that
I can't tell I thought they were like
hooking up at one boy yeah they talk to
each other I don't know any brother and
sister who talk like that with each
other I don't have a brother so I don't
know this dynamic there's no idea how is
you talk like that with your sisters god
no they look like they're [ __ ]
flirting with each other the whole time
maybe like off-camera there's like a
look yeah thank you couple they would be
a cute couple I really thought they were
dating
yeah the first parts of the trailer I
thought were like okay whatever but when
it got into his death and the visual
imagery started changing I thought it
got a lot cooler I like the kind of
psychological we had this yeah
another that's probably your thing huh
no no well I thought it was like you
know rom-com my god calm and exact we're
feeling like yes like oh the brother
died oh she's losing her mom but there
was a mother some reason didn't you want
to tell me no she's so good well I've
seen all there's only three Harry Potter
movies right I kind of like the weird
eeriness parts of it I like the touch of
is he is she just grieving and she's
imagining seeing him or is he like a
ghost of he launching what do you think
I would like the movie if it went down a
path where he actually is a ghost
haha my guess is that it's a it's more
of a psychological thing she has going
on yeah because everything they're going
through like when it's titled text was
about like grief issues and stuff and
trying to live up to what her brother
wanted her to be like and what her
brother would approve or disapprove of
because I like the idea that you'd like
this ghost that kind of blames her and
hates her a little bit you know my tribe
you know like II was driving right yeah
he was driving I think so yeah he was
the one behind the wheel so what's he
like
Oh maybe like they were fighting and
like she's like stop what brother would
take the time to drive and take his eyes
off the road and look at the sister much
less there was nothing going on I think
there was an incest thing happening I'm
down for that
but hey kudos to the movie if it's doing
that it isn't because that's always
disturbing a Zelda boy watch it I mean
it might be one of the things to where
she never had a brother
oh thanks I'll take all our own
imagination yeah but she seems like
Jesus legit crazy but I like an approach
to a movie that takes a psychological
turn on what dealing with grief is like
are you into hot crazy like that like is
that your type of one hot crazy
yeah totally yeah only hot crazy yeah
that's why you're not my type yeah
you're hot you're normal you're bland
boring Lauren there's the typical woman
I'm sorry I didn't mean that this one
was a nightmare
it's a different kind of crazy maybe
like compliment women call push fool
[Laughter]
girl rejects click the notification
valve hey why won't my bull ring on
everything in the world I want my Laura
fall over there what's the thing you use
the most YouTube YouTube is the main
thing years follow her on YouTube check
out some sketches on there also I'm in a
couple of sketches with her and I have
another one I am one of her that was
coming up and she just filmed some
videos my brother Jeff echo it keep a
lookout for those videos as well Lauren
it is late at night and you have a drive
to go to to your home I'm cutting the
camera cuz I'm I use of filming as much
as you all right